a chess player may play thousands or
even millions of moves in their lifetime
but let's face it some moves are better
than others there are daily brilliances
and blunders but there are also truly
special moves that every chess player
aspires to play at some point your
bucket list moves if you will some are
extremely difficult to engineer without
your opponent's help while some though
rare are almost certain to cross your
path if you play chess long enough in
any case without further Ado here are 10
chess moves that you have to play in
your lifetime smothered mate is the
classic chess combination that blows
every chess player's mind on the first
encounter the idea of sacrificing the
almighty Queen simply to block one
square approaches the miraculous when
you've never seen it before while
beautiful smothered mate is not that
uncommon and you will encounter it if
you play enough games and have a sharp
eye here for example is the popular
streamer Lula robs checking smothered
mate off of her bucket list after less
than a year of play
possibly the rarest chess move on this
list opposite Checkmate is a spectacular
convergence of chess's most memeable
role and the glory of a Victorious
Checkmate yes
on passant there we go every so often
you'll see a great ampasan Checkmate
going viral but no opusan Checkmate can
rival the Masterpiece recently
engineered by Norwegian Grandmaster Yoon
Ludwig Hammer against his childhood
friend and the greatest chess player of
all time Magnus Carlson
check
are we seeing a trade oh 95 I did not
say that kind of Lucky that's not mates
oh it is mates
oh wow uh okay I'm going to let him make
me of course
okay nice once a pawn has struggled
across seven ranks of a war-torn
chessboard it receives a well-earned
honor promotion to any chess piece of
its choosing barring the king while one
can choose a knight bishop or Rook for
promotion one almost always chooses to
promote to a Queen by far the most
powerful piece on the chessboard after
all
still there are special cases like the
famous savedra study where one promotes
to a rook to avoid stalemate or my
personal favorite study of all time by
Diller where one promotes to a bishop
also to avoid stalemate the most common
underpromotion is to ignite usually to
give a crushing and forcing check that a
queen simply cannot give here is an
incredible example from the wildly
popular samairina of a winning under
promotion opportunity you just have to
remember to hold alt to turn off auto
Queen
and I'm almost hoping for him to take
the queen and at this point my heart was
in my mouth I was like oh my God oh my
God and then
I push the pawn
oh what we
are Auto come on man I have Auto Pokemon
and I honestly any stalemate trap is
worth having on your bucket list for
example the Raging Rook Reckless Rook or
roving Rook depending on who is naming
it is a pretty combination and it is by
far the best way to rack up some
brilliant chess moves in your game
however there is one stalemate trap that
stands apart in distinction and
dirtiness Eric rosen's famous idea to
bait his opponent into a simplifying
Queen exchange and pre-move his King
into the corner has worked not once but
twice in prize competition on chess.com
most recently in his I'm not a GM speed
chess match against now Grandmaster
Elizabeth hates I think of your air
version you really do want to waste time
off the mesh clock oh my gosh tell me
that's why you don't resign that was
still me any good chess tactics book has
one pattern in it that feels like it is
only completely different level than all
of the other tactical patterns bearing
the Vivid and accurate moniker the
windmill this pattern features an
amazing sequence of repeated discovered
checks that can be used to win a nearly
unlimited amount of material the most
famous windmill is definitely the one
played my Mexican Prodigy Carlos Torre
against former world champion Emmanuel
Lasker but Bobby Fischer's game of the
century also features a windmill here's
another one that I really like white
starts with a rook sacrifice that leads
to a combination of Bishop and Rook
checks that simply consume Black's
forces
the LA Fong is a dirty dirty trick that
will probably only work at bullet but
you have to pull it off at least once in
your life when you sense that your
opponent is pre-moving G6 and Bishop G7
to start the game you can play D4 and
Bishop H6 to try to win the bishop on G7
thanks guys
no one is watching oh
oh they all missed that I see the Tilt I
can feel the tilt
[Laughter]
it is a high risk and high reward
strategy because you are hanging your
own Bishop if you don't catch them in a
pre-move but it is certainly hilarious
when you do pull it off
like one of my friends acios he made a
bot the reporter was partly based on
hyperbolic games then you could see a
lot of the lafang some Queen C2 takes H7
and so on so the bishop and nine
Checkmate may had the highest difficulty
on this list even Hikaru struggled to
execute it in a recent tournament he
might not do that you might not be able
to do it he's down to 25. Kevin oh
Bishop B3 and he needs to get this way
he's going he's going Hikaru with a draw
for he didn't do it probably motivating
every other top player to brush up on
the pattern in a different recent event
Dania neraditsky showcased his Mastery
of the steam
that's how you do it hey Caro you do not
have to execute the bishop and knight
checkmate as quickly as Danya did here
you can also practice it on chess.com in
games highly recommended
if the bomb cloud is good enough for
akarnakamura and Magnus Carlsen by golly
it is good enough for the rest of us
knowing that all this craziness is
happening with the qualification what
and Manus goes don't do this
[Music]
in one of the most famous games of all
time Edward Lasker declined to Checkmate
his opponent by castling
more recently Peter's Fiddler forced his
opponent bishwanathan Anand to earn his
win by castling
I played King F7 and before he could
react I looked up and said Bishop police
Castle he was somewhat surprised and
then he smiled and did Castle probably
this will end up the one of my games in
my entire life which will end by castles
check on move 31. chain pre-moves are a
special feature on the chess.com website
only not yet on the apps you can stack
as many pre-moves as you want no matter
what your opponent plays if the
pre-moves are legal moves they will be
executed when you have a dominating
position or a thoroughly forced
combination you can use chain Primus to
deliver the Checkmate it's a pretty
special feeling of power but it's also
tricky here's an example of it almost
being perfectly executed by Ludwig in a
famous POG Champs moment
oh my don't do it he's gonna do it don't
do it don't do it
now here is an example of Dania the
prophet neridditsky seamlessly executing
a Checkmate through chained Primos
foreign
there you have it 10 chest moves that
you have got to play in your lifetime
personally I've done six out of 10 of
these so far hopefully I have a few
years left to get in for more post to
your number in the comments down below
thanks so much for watching this video I
had an absolute blast making it and I
also had a blast making this other video
on the 10 most beautiful checkmates ever
played check it out if you're interested